j'arrive petit bonsoir directeur du
comité des Yvelines de la prévention
routière nous allons revenir avec vous
durant les prochaines minutes sur deux
campagnes de sensibilisation qui sont en
cours actuellement à moins d'un mois des
fêtes de fin d'année vous êtes mobilisés
je rappelle que l'alcool demeure la
première cause d'accidents mortel sur
les routes et la période de fin d'année
nécessite une attention une vigilance
particulière pour vos services alors
pour mon service moi j'ai pas de service
nous sommes une association
comme vous le dites la c'est la première
cause d'accident mortel sur la route y
compris dans notre département donc il
est très important à l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année que les gens soient
bien conscients qu'il faut faire
attention à l'alcool sur l'argent c'est
chaque année vous le constatez un petit
peu moins peut-être non
mais il faut qu'on continue nos efforts
nous c'est pour cette raison que nous
nous mobilisons pour les opérations sam
capitaine de soirée que je crois tout le
monde connaît maintenant celui qui
conduit c'est celui qui boit pas et nous
serons le samedi 15 décembre avec les
bénévoles à part les deux pour
distribuer les éthylotest et des flyers
justement vous parlez de ces éthydotest
normalement ils étaient obligatoires et
c'était même verbalisables avant la fin
de cette année dès le mois de novembre
finalement c'est repoussé à mars 2013
est-ce que vous regrettez ce délai
supplémentaire accordé que tout n'est
pas été mis en tout cas en œuvre pour
permettre que ce soit rapidement non
opérationnel nous le but n'est pas que
ça soit verbalisable que les gens soient
punis avec les gens qu'on en parle et
que les gens prennent conscience donc
chez les gens sont punis tant pis pour
eux mais c'est pas le but que nous
recherchons donc si ça arrive le premier
s'il y a suffisamment d'éthylotest sur
le marché tant mieux donc ensuite ce
sera je le rappelle tout de même
verbalisable au 1er mars 2013 on parle
donc prévention routière ce soir et la
tension portée en cette période de fin
d'année notamment sur les jeunes vous
mobilisez principalement auprès des
jeunes avec l'opération vous l'avez
mentionné tout à l'heure Sam Sam c'est
le capitaine de soirée celui qui conduit
c'est celui qui ne boit pas exactement
ça porte ses fruits cette opération ça
marche pas mal tous les jeunes à qui
j'en parle même à vous enfin tout le
monde tout le monde connaît Sam le
capitaine de soirée et tout le monde
connaît l'opération donc nous avons
lancé pour trois mois une une
application sur Facebook qui s'appelle
vidsam et qui va permettre par une
plateforme de d'échange du bottes
communautaire à tous les capitaines de
soirée d'échanger leurs expériences et
tous les 15 jours l'expérience qui
aurait été la plus likée c'est comme ça
qu'il faut dire c'est très bien gagnera
une mise en bande dessinée et celui qui
aura qui aura posté cette cette
expérience gagnera un t-shirt donc ça a
été mis principalement en place donc
vous l'avez dit à trois mois destination
plutôt des jeunes alors ça a été mis en
place il y a un mois ça va durer trois
mois et à la fin de la campagne celui
qui aura posté la meilleure expérience
gagnera une soirée en limousine avec
chauffeur pour pouvoir faire la fête
avec ses amis avec moi
avec modération et au moins il sera sûr
de rentrer chez lui et il y a bien
évidemment cette opération et
s'accompagne aussi d'une sensibilisation
dans les lieux d'études dans les
universités également notamment auprès
des bureaux des étudiants les fameux BDE
pour ceux qui sont encore en université
ou en école vous envoyer des
informations des kits également oui j'ai
d'ailleurs rendez-vous prochainement
avec l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin pour pour proposer mes
services
les associations d'étudiants nous
connaissent déjà pour beaucoup mais il y
a toujours besoin de se faire connaître
mieux nous étions la semaine dernière à
HEC pour une séance de sensibilisation
où nous parlons bien évidemment aux
associations d'étudiants et au bureau
des élèves au BDE de les opérations
capitaine de soirée je les incite à
venir me voir quand ils organisent des
soirées et moi je leur donne des
éthylotests des bracelets pour
identifier les capitaines de soirée des
affiches des flyers évidemment des
conseils pour les aider à organiser leur
soirée parce que c'est bien les
étudiants
qui organise ça c'est pas moi je veux
parler à 4h du matin m'assurer que tout
le monde est sage mais là au final ça
reste ça reste festif c'est fait sur sur
un ton plutôt léger de sensibilisation à
côté de ça il y a des campagnes qui sont
plutôt violentes on envoie quelques
images qui sont diffusées et quelquefois
uniquement sur internet ça fonctionne de
la même manière c'est de type c'est
complémentaires parce que on peut se
dire que des campagnes plus violentes
fonctionnent peut-être mieux que l'idée
de sam capitaine de soirée avec ce
bonhomme sympathique je pense que les
décan c'est chez moi le bonhomme
sympathique j'espère je parlais du petit
bonhomme qui représente Sam mais des
campagnes violentes il y en avait eu
dans le passé à la télévision où à
l'étranger là maintenant si vous
remarquez l'administration de l'État pas
nous mais l'état passe régulièrement des
spots à la télévision ou la violence est
suggéré elle n'est plus montrée
réellement elle est suggée et ça frappe
tout autant j'espère les téléspectateurs
mais non montrer de l'hémoglobine
partout c'est pas peut-être pas la
meilleure solution je reste sur cette
opération sam capitaine de après c'est
une approche il faut de tout trouver
plusieurs phase avec il faut de tout il
faut être il faut aller au contact des
gens et des jeunes en particulier et
pour les les attirer les intéresser il
faut il faut être à leur à leur écoute
enfin leur niveau quoi alors l'Autre
Campagne que vous soutenez en cette
période c'est la campagne contre l'usage
du téléphone portable au volant c'est un
phénomène qui se banalise de plus
souvent de plus en plus souvent on
utilise son portable pas forcément pour
téléphoner d'ailleurs c'est aussi pour
envoyer des SMS ou pour même chercher sa
route sur internet avec les smartphones
maintenant c'est rendu beaucoup plus
facile utilisez-vous votre téléphone au
volant nous sommes allés vous poser la
question on va écouter vos réponses et
puis juste après nous parlons donc de
cette campagne menée par la prévention
routière en cette période de fin d'année
maintenant je viens d'avoir une amende
alors il y a deux mois donc à cause de
ça et donc c'est fini j'arrête d'appeler
non de recevoir oui mais j'ai un kit
main libre mains libre non jamais je
viens juste d'avoir mon permis il y a
trois semaines donc non
encore non plus
pas téléphone du tout
j'évite de le faire il y a des cas
particuliers
des cas particuliers je mets
l'oreillette bon voilà je mets
l'oreillette et puis
aussi non je m'arrête sur le bord de la
route jamais parce que j'ai un
équipement dans ma dans mon véhicule
ni sms ni niveau calme non jamais trop
dangereux
les 5 continents n'utilise jamais leur
téléphone portable vous voyez les
opérations portent leurs fruits sur le
bassin de 50 ans en Yvelines sur le
département des Yvelines j'ai tout de
même donné un chiffre et c'est beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins drôle 10% des
accidents corporels de la route sont
imputables à l'utilisation du téléphone
au volant c'est un phénomène qui se
banalise aujourd'hui véritablement oui
et votre reportage je sais pas si vous
avez fait le tri dans les réponses et
vous avez interrogé un seul jeune moi je
peux vous dire que aujourd'hui 75% des
jeunes de 18 à 24 ans des jeunes
conducteurs à vous téléphonez enfin
téléphoner au volant utilisez leur
téléphone ou leur smartphone pas
forcément
particulièrement dangereux et c'est
monté de façon spectaculaire en disant
75% des jeunes le font et surtout ils
n'ont pas conscience que c'est dangereux
et considère que c'est une petite
infraction mais non pas conscience que
c'est réellement dangereux or vous avez
dit 10% les accidents corporels mais 18%
les accidents modèle de la route sont
directement liées à l'utilisage à
l'usage pardon l'utilisation du
téléphone donc c'est un phénomène
dramatique et c'est pour ça que nous
lançons donc une deuxième campagne au
volant je passe en mode voiture en a vu
quelques images d'ailleurs pendant que
vous vous répondiez exactement donc au
volant je passe en mode voiture
ce sont des images qui passent sur tous
les médias internet
Facebook justement son compte sur les
sur les réseaux sociaux et puis on va
simuler virtuellement les mauvaises
conduites et son accident absolument
alors il s'agit de ne pas le faire au
volant bien évidemment sinon
mais c'est bien le but donc de
sensibiliser les jeunes par là où ils
sont où on peut les toucher facilement
c'est-à-dire toute Internet YouTube
Facebook etc quels sont les retours que
vous avez même chose sur ce genre
d'opération on reste sur quelque chose
qui reste une fois de plus ça assez
léger on se connecte sur Internet est-ce
que pour autant il y a une prise de
conscience derrière et est-ce que ça va
permettre à ces jeunes qui utilisent
massivement vous l'avez dit 76% des 18
24 ans qui déclarent utiliser leur
téléphone au volant est-ce qu'ils vont
arrêter du jour au lendemain alors je
pense je pense que c'est je suis pas
certain mais je pense que c'est la
première fois que nous que nous faisons
ça la prévention routière donc nous en
tirons les conséquences bien évidemment
ça c'est une campagne au niveau national
bien sûr nous en tirerons les
conséquences mais je pense que l'idée
est bonne et qu'il faut continuer et de
toute façon vous le savez nous
intervenons avec les bénévoles qui
m'entourent une nouvelle fois je fais un
appel au bénévoles parce que j'ai besoin
de bénévoles pour venir travailler avec
moi nous intervenons dans les
entreprises dans les lycées dans les
collèges et à chaque fois nous
expliquons les dangers du téléphone au
volant téléphone et maintenant on va
ajouter smartphone et tout le reste je
ne parle pas uniquement de la répression
dire que ça coûte cher trois points
enfin et puis une personne l'a dit dans
votre reportage mais c'est réellement
dangereux parce que quand on est dans
son téléphone ou dans son smartphone on
ne fait plus attention au reste ça c'est
valable d'ailleurs aussi pour les
piétons qui traversent en téléphonant et
qui est donc sont moins attentifs à la
circulation donc ça veut dire que le kit
main libre les oreillettes aussi alors
au volant nous dans l'idéal nous la
prévention routière nous souhaiterions
que tout téléphone soit interdit en
voiture maintenant il faut faire des
choses qui soient acceptées partout
c'est raisonnable donc nous souhaitons
que les pouvoirs publics
incitent les constructeurs auto et les
équipementsiers à équiper les voitures
de systèmes de plus en plus automatisés
avec des commandes vocales par exemple
pour qu'il y a de moins en moins de
manipulation manuelle à faire pour
téléphoner même avec un kit main libre
qui reste toujours
malgré tout manipuler pour l'instant
donc nous c'est extrapole un petit peu
les autoradios aussi ça distrait de
l'art c'est pas c'est pas pareil
l'autoradio c'est pas si d'ailleurs
vous-même j'imagine quand vous faites
une manœuvre au cas de la situation
la circulation devient un peu compliqué
vous baissez le son ou vous coupez en
tout cas moi c'est ce que je fais et en
tout c'est passif vous n'êtes pas dans
la conversation vous n'êtes pas
directement sollicité dans les quand
vous êtes au téléphone vous avez un
interlocuteur qui vous parle qui sait
d'ailleurs pas forcément que vous êtes
au téléphone et c'est pas bien il faut
lui dire je suis au téléphone je peux
pas répondre et répondre ça ira aussi
vite ça veut dire absolument bien sûr
merci d'être venu nous parler de ces
deux opérations une toute dernière
question est-ce qu'il y a justement
démobilisation des opérations
sensibilisation qui sont prévues d'ici
la fin de l'année même pendant les
périodes de fête que vous allez
organiser avec la prévention routière ah
bah il y a mentionné le sel du 15
décembre dans les centres commerciaux
pour l'instant pour l'instant c'est tout
parce que les bénévoles et moi-même
voulons profiter de nos fêtes aussi mais
il y aura d'autres responsabilité de
chacun un peu différentes campagnes qui
ont été lancées merci donc Jean-Yves
petit pour ce passage sur le plateau du
7 8 cette édition du 26 novembre se
poursuit avec le rappel des titres à
présent l'actualité à retenir dans les
Yvelines elle est Resto du Coeur lancent
leur 28e campagne Seto Clayes-sous-Bois
que sont stockés les dents et
alimentaires qui approvisionnent les 26
centres du département en 2012 plus d'un
million d'euros a été servi une nouvelle
maison de Coville à avoisin le
Bretonneux inauguré ce samedi soir vous
allez en voir les images un travail mené
par l'architecte Fabien Duchenne coup
des travaux 1,4 millions d'euros ils
sont 7 athlètes handisport à avoir
intégré la section tennis de table du
club d'Élancourt la section a été créée
il y a deux ans sous l'impulsion de
Florence sirogo l'athlète qui est à
participer aux Jeux paralympiques de
Londres cette année un club de bowling
qui a passé qui plus vite que son ombre
le club d'Élancourt compte une vingtaine
de membres les entraînements ont lieu à
Maurepas et l'une des plus importantes
écoles d'Île-de-France vous avez
découvert ce sujet lors de notre page de
sport du lundi 60 000 bénévoles des
Restos qui se mobilisent donc depuis ce
matin pour combattre la crise depuis 3
ans le nombre de bénéficiaires a
progressé de 25% au resto du coeur alors
que les ressources sont toujours
menacées la direction Les
Clayes-sous-Bois Johanna Soudry et le
Diwan
Maurice Glory est retraité et bénévole
au resto du coeur depuis plus de deux
ans il s'occupe de l'entrepôt de
l'association basée aux Clayes-sous-Bois
l'année dernière l'équipe des bénévoles
a préparé 1400 palettes pour
approvisionner les 26 centres que compte
le département des Yvelines
d'articles pour la distribution donc ça
va surtout ce qui l'accompagnement
classique les pâtes le riz les conserve
après vous avez toute une série de
protides
tout ce qui est conserve de poisson tout
ce qui est produit surgelés vous avez
après du dessert
et des produits laitiers l'objectif des
restos fournir au bénéficiaires un repas
complet et équilibré les besoins
varieront selon les centres les plus
petits pourront servir 120 repas par
semaine tandis que les plus importants
en distribueront 4000 l'entrepos stock
plus de 80% de marchandises alimentaires
le reste se répartit entre produits
d'hygiène et d'entretien pour les bébés
couches les deux croissances et petits
pots destinés à près de 500 nourrissons
chaque semaine si la campagne divers des
Restos du cœur vient juste de débuter à
l'entrepôt on prépare déjà les palettes
pour la semaine suivante la distribution
commence ce matin et on est parti pour
officiellement cette semaine mais
traditionnellement fait 17 semaines on
démarre en début de ton début de
campagne à 45000 et on finira plus de 60
minutes le nombre de bénéficiaires ne
cesse de croître et les bénévoles sont
plus que jamais recherchés autre
difficulté la disparition du Programme
européen d'aide au plus démunis ça
représente
20 à 25% des approvisionnements ici
donc si brutalement ça disparaît je
pense qu'on n'a pas de solution
instantanée pour remplacer ça donc on
espère que les politiques seront
mobilisés pour maintenir ce budget
le 78 est terminé pour aujourd'hui
prochain rendez-vous avec l'information
à 20h30 et à 22h sur téléfils 78 je vous
retrouve demain dès 18h en direct
excellente soirée